Mike this is a hell of a drop is this
entirely down to people trying to avoid
the new rates of tax significantly so I
think if you looked at March which was
our paper sent you saying that you're
now down 20% that's a significant shift
but remember April is a relatively small
month it's about a quarter of what March
was so you can see an absolute movement
of people bringing forward those
purchases to avoid the increase in road
tax which clearly makes sense and what
proportion of motorists will be hit by
these new rates of excise duty
well then most motorists I mean the way
the road taxes structures you have a
first year rate and then you go to a
different rate up until the 1st of April
about two-thirds of new car buyers for
that first year weren't paying any road
tax and that was probably an equitable
the government wanted to change it so
they've tried to spread it out a bit
more so basically most car drivers will
be affected and roughly how much extra
will a motorist be paying in these new
tax rates
well there's again a difference been the
first year and then for the subsequent
years after in first year things have
gone up by say 10 15 % then it moves to
a flat rate of 140 pounds from first
drivers who were driving more
fuel-efficient cars that's a rise for
those or larger cars it's it's closer to
parity but what is also in there is an
increase on the most expensive cars
those cars over 40,000 pounds in value
pay even more hence that movement over
the two months now obviously during the
last five years or so if not longer than
that I mean new car sales have been on
an absolute tear was that previous rate
of growth sustainable for much longer
huh we were at an all-time record last
year was the best year ever for new car
sales and that beat the previous record
which was the previous year so at some
state now and it's also important to
remember and there's a reporter mention
there we are still at historically high
levels so there is that demand there we
expect over the course of the year more
stabilization perhaps over the full year
maybe a job of about 5% it really
depends on consumer confidence what
happens in terms of inflation how that
flows through to the price of cars I
mean the most stunning aspect of these
statistics was the drop-off in diesel
27% I mean is this category doomed
again you can there's always dangers and
looking in one particular month in March
we had the record ever number of diesel
cars sold and somewhat somewhat weirdly
if you look at April that proportion of
diesel sales actually went up compared
to March so that is that just reveals
that danger of looking at one in a one
month in isolation what we do see is
there's still demand for diesel because
it offers that fuel economy which is
often a driver of purchasing there is
some uncertainty around what's going to
happen with the clean air zones and we
expect an announcement by government
imminently but what I think will happen
was you know what you see in London that
the new cars and new diesels which is so
much cleaner than the old ones are
exempt from any of these measures have
you been able to speak to a study con
about this because he's obviously one of
those who's in the sort of forefront of
this campaign against diesel he is and I
don't think it's a specific air campaign
against diesel what they want to do
rightly so is address air quality and
Road Transport does make a contribution
to that the important thing to recognize
is you know we all depend on Road
Transport whether it's for personal
transport or delivery of goods services
emergency services so it'd be wrong just
to penalize diesel because some of the
vehicles there is no choice in terms of
the speed of HGVs for instance what we
are seeing though is you know the
investment by manufacturers to put ever
cleaner technologies on the road which
will be part of the solution that we
need on air quality in the urban towns
and cities so briefly might ward your
expectations for the rest of the year
over the year we think the market will
probably the plea will stabilize this is
an erratic two months you know
determined by these tax changes probably
the market will be down slightly maybe
four or five percent but in historical
terms that's still at a very very high
level alright Michael is going to leave
it there thanks for joining me